will the new ipad 10 come with a full  redesign just like we got with all of  the other ipads like the ipad pro the  ipad air and the ipad mini or will apple  choose to stick around with the old  design for just another year before i  get into the exclusive new leaks from 9  to 5 mac i want to make the point that  apple's budget ipad is essentially like  the youngest kid in the family who  receives all of the hand-me-downs from  the older siblings now moving on to 95  max exclusive leaks they reported that  the new ipad will come with the a14 ship  5g usbc  and a retina display of the same  resolution as the ipad airs display i  have a feeling that 9 to 5 max sources  are right about usbc coming to the  budget ipad this year which i think  means that we will be getting a full  redesign and you should definitely wait  three more months until that ipad comes  out before you make any major ipad  purchasing decisions